Now let's go back to
the topic of raid 4 writes.
Let's say we have raid
4 with five disks here.
And let's look at just one set
of stripes with their parity.
And now let's say we want
to write new content to D0.
So of course here,
we will have changed the data.
And the remaining data disks don't
have any changes to their data.
But the question is how do
we compute a new parity?
One way of doing that would be to read
the data from the other three disks and
XOR that with the new
content in the fourth disk.
But that would result in three reads and
a write.
If N is even larger that will
increase the number of reads we need
to do the write.
So instead, we are going to figure
out how to update this parity.
What we need to know is
what was the old data and
the new data with we XOR these we get
which bits of the data have changed.
If we know the old parity,
and this XOR change and
we XOR the two together, we get to flip
all the bits of the old parity that
would change as a result of the bits.
So basically a flip in the data
here would result in
a flip in the parity here.
We can compute it, what to flip,
XORing with the old parity flips it and
that's what you write to the new parity.
So that's why we have a read and
a write of the old parity.
In addition we have a read of the old
data if we don't already know it.
And we know the new data.
So basically we have
a read from the data disk.
A read from the parity disk.
A write to the data disk and
a write to the parity disk.
And the parity disk will be a bottleneck
because the four disks here
are accessed by writes in a way
that reads and writes one disk.
Another write would maybe read and write
this disk but all of these read and
write the parity disk, so
it becomes a bottleneck.
Because the parity disk is
a bottleneck for writes,
we have RAID 5 which has exactly the
same reliability property as RAID 4 and
very similar read performance, but
it fixes the write performance.